Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Oh, sleep, oh, gentle sleep, nature's soft nurse, how have I frighted thee that thou wilt no more weigh my eyelids down and steep my senses in forgetfulness? Wilt thou, upon the high and giddy mast, seal up the ship-boy's eyes, and rock his brains in cradle of the rude, imperious surge, and in the visitation of the winds, who take the ruffian billows by the top, curling their monstrous heads, and hanging them with deafening
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。哦，睡眠，哦，温柔的睡眠，大自然的软护士，我怎么惊吓了你，使你不再压下我的眼睑，让我的感官沉浸在遗忘之中？你难道会在那高耸而眩晕的桅杆上，封住那船童的眼睛，在粗暴、专横的巨浪摇篮中摇晃他的大脑，在狂风的造访中，那狂风抓住了那粗暴的波浪的顶端，卷起它们那可怕的头颅，并将它们悬挂在震耳欲聋的
clamour in the slippery clouds, that with the hurly death itself awakes. Canst thou, O partial sleep, Give thy repose to the wet seaboy In an hour so rude, And in the calmest and most stillest night, With all appliances and means to boot, Deny it to a king? Then happy low lie down, Uneasy lies the head that wears a crown.
喧嚣中，挂在湿滑的云层里，以至于连死亡本身都在那喧闹中惊醒。难道你，哦，偏心的睡眠，竟能在那如此粗暴的时刻，将你的安宁给予那潮湿的船童，却在最平静、最寂静的夜晚，即便拥有所有的辅助手段和方法，却拒绝给予一位国王？那么，快乐的卑微者躺下吧，戴着王冠的头颅总是不得安宁。
So those are the words of the dying King Henry IV in Shakespeare's play, Henry IV, Part 2. And Tom, we were talking about this just before we started recording. Shakespeare's plays, Henry IV, Part 1 and 2, are my favorite shakespeare plays and mine oh tom well we know this don't we because we went together to see rich the second henry the fourth part one henry the fourth part two and henry the fifth yeah in one day yeah at the roundhouse and i've completely forgotten that i went with you you did apologies for that
这些是莎士比亚戏剧《亨利四世（下篇）》中垂死的亨利四世国王的台词。汤姆，我们在录音前刚聊到这个。莎士比亚的《亨利四世（上篇）》和《下篇》是我最喜欢的莎士比亚剧作，也是我的，哦，汤姆，我们都知道这一点，不是吗？因为我们曾一起去圆屋剧场（Roundhouse）看了《理查二世》、《亨利四世（上篇）》、《亨利四世（下篇）》和《亨利五世》，是的，在一天之内，是的，在圆屋剧场，我完全忘了我是和你一起去的，你确实忘了，对此表示抱歉。
we were remembering that we'd both seen the production and you were talking about it clearly as though you'd been with somebody else and i was slightly offended by that that uh i'd been eclipsed in your recollection yeah i'm very sorry yeah and then you described it as an ordeal a pleasant ordeal yeah there was a lot of shakespeare to be fair four plays that's a lot of plays that's a lot of my lord of worcester doth come kind of stuff it was but i agree the henry the fourth part one and two, I think are, I mean, among his greatest plays. And they are indisputably the greatest plays set in a period of history, I think, ever written. And I think that it constitutes a dramatic epic that no other nation has. A series of plays that
我们当时在回忆我们都看过那场演出，你谈论它时，语气显然就像你是和别人一起去的一样，我对此感到有点被冒犯了，呃，我在你的记忆中被掩盖了，是的，我很抱歉，是的，然后你把它描述为一种磨难，一种愉快的磨难，是的，说实话，莎士比亚的内容太多了，四部剧，那可是很多剧，那有很多“伍斯特伯爵来了”之类的东西，确实如此，但我同意，《亨利四世（上篇）》和《下篇》，我认为，我的意思是，是他最伟大的剧作之一。而且我认为它们无疑是有史以来写过的以特定历史时期为背景的最伟大的剧作。我认为这构成了一部没有任何其他国家所拥有的戏剧史诗。一系列的剧作，
have been performed since they were first staged and the consequence of that is that the period of history that we embarked on when we did we did rich the second and we'll be going through the 15th century yeah people are familiar with it in a way that they're not with other periods of medieval history so it has this kind of incredible resonance and power do you think i think it absolutely does i I think you have Henry IV, the usurper. So people who listened to our previous series about medieval history will remember that he kicked Richard II out as king of England, his cousin. And you have the whole drama of the usurper taking power,
自首次上演以来就一直被演出，其结果是，当我们开始制作《理查二世》时，我们将经历15世纪，是的，人们对它有一种熟悉感，而对中世纪历史的其他时期则没有，所以它有一种不可思议的共鸣和力量，你觉得呢？我绝对认为有，我认为你有亨利四世，那个篡位者。所以听过我们之前关于中世纪历史系列节目的听众会记得，他把理查二世赶下了英格兰国王的宝座，那是他的表亲。你有篡位者夺权的全部戏剧性，
very George R. R. Martin, Game of Thrones, you know, uneasy lies the head that wears a crown, all of that stuff. I mean, one of his most famous lines. Yeah, but then running through these plays, and indeed running through this series that we're going to be doing the relationship between henry the usurper and his son prince hal in the plays who goes on to become the great hero king henry v and it's that relationship in the plays that elevates them because it's kind of paralleled by hal's relationship with their tremendous character i think's fair to say, even though he hasn't appeared in the rest of his history, he will be a great friend of the rest of his history. Sir John Falstaff.
非常有乔治·R·R·马丁《权力的游戏》的感觉，你知道，“戴着王冠的头颅总是不得安宁”，所有这些东西。我的意思是，他最著名的台词之一。是的，但贯穿这些剧作，实际上也贯穿我们将要制作的这个系列，是篡位者亨利和他在剧中的儿子哈尔王子之间的关系，哈尔王子后来成为了伟大的英雄国王亨利五世，正是剧中这种关系提升了它们，因为它与哈尔和那个了不起的角色之间的关系相平行，我认为可以这么说，尽管他没有出现在《历史的余味》中，但他将成为《历史的余味》的一位伟大的朋友。约翰·法斯塔夫爵士。
Yeah. Yeah. Because Prince Howe is off supposedly wassailing with Falstaff and all the lads down in Cheapside and everything. And so one of the reasons why these plays are so brilliant is that you do have lots of you know the earl of westmoreland rushing in with four score men and that kind of thing but you also have these incredible portraits of life as it is being lived down in the seamy underbelly of london yeah with this incredibly entertaining figure full stuff who will be talking about later in this series and Henry IV Part II, if you like. And just to say that if people haven't seen either of these plays or read them, a very easy way to have some familiarity with them is to watch a film that Orson Welles made in the mid-1960s,
是的。是的。因为哈尔王子据说是和法斯塔夫以及切普赛德（Cheapside）的所有小伙子们一起狂欢什么的。所以这些剧作之所以如此精彩的原因之一是，你确实有很多，你知道，威斯特摩兰伯爵带着八十人冲进来之类的事情，但你也有这些关于伦敦阴暗面生活的不可思议的写照，是的，还有这个极其有趣的法斯塔夫人物，我们稍后会在这个系列中谈到他，如果你喜欢的话，还有《亨利四世（下篇）》。只想说，如果人们还没有看过这两部剧或读过它们，熟悉它们的一个非常简单的方法是观看奥逊·威尔斯在20世纪60年代中期制作的一部电影，
very groovy, called The chimes at midnight and i think his best film after citizen kane it's lots of people in kind of new avengers leather and you've got jean moreau looking very glamorous kind of dolly bird yeah it's really really good it has one of the best medieval battle scenes you will ever see kind of mist nights looming out of it's really brilliant anyway so absolutely one of my favorite films henry the fourth but one and two my favorite plays so hugely looking forward to this if people are really interested there's also a bbc version called the hollow crown taking those words yeah that's great as well and that's tom hiddleston as prince hal and my favorite actor of all simon Russell Beale, as Falstaff.
非常时髦，叫《午夜钟声》（Chimes at Midnight），我认为这是他继《公民凯恩》之后最好的电影，里面有很多穿着类似《新复仇者》那种皮衣的人，还有看起来非常迷人的珍妮·莫罗，那种时髦女郎，是的，它真的非常非常好，它有你所能见过的最好的中世纪战斗场景之一，那种迷雾中若隐若现的骑士，真的很精彩，总之，绝对是我最喜欢的电影之一，《亨利四世（上篇）》和《下篇》是我最喜欢的剧作，所以非常期待这个，如果人们真的很感兴趣，还有一个BBC版本叫《空王冠》（The Hollow Crown），采用了那些台词，是的，那也很棒，那是汤姆·希德勒斯顿饰演哈尔王子，还有我最喜欢的演员西蒙·拉塞尔·比尔饰演法斯塔夫。
So you can watch that as well. But anyway, Tom, we're not just a podcast that advertises other people's productions. We have productions of our own. I'm expecting a top performance here because we've set the bar very high with the talk of the roundhouse and Tom Hiddleston and whatnot. Okay, well, no pressure. So you're going to be taking us through it,
所以你也可以看那个。但总之，汤姆，我们不仅仅是一个为别人的作品做广告的播客。我们有我们自己的作品。我期待这里有顶级的表现，因为我们通过谈论圆屋剧场和汤姆·希德勒斯顿等等，把标准定得很高。好的，好吧，没有压力。所以你将带我们了解它，
but there's a paradox here, isn't there, which is that Henry IV, parts parts one and two are very famous plays but henry the fourth himself is a slightly obscure figure and will be to a lot of our listeners and to many of our overseas listeners i'm guessing will probably never have heard of him and have no sense of him why is that do you think when he's actually got such an interesting story he's he he topples his cousin he takes the crown his he's a usurper, he's insecure, his son goes on to be the great hero king. Why don't we know more about Henry IV? It is interesting because in the Henry IV plays, I mean, he's quite a shadowy figure. He's very kind of weary, he's careworn. I mean,
但这里有一个悖论，不是吗？那就是《亨利四世（上篇）》和《下篇》是非常著名的剧作，但亨利四世本人却是一个稍微有点默默无闻的人物，对于我们的许多听众来说，对于我们的许多海外听众来说，我猜他们可能从来没听说过他，对他没有任何概念，你认为为什么会这样呢？当他实际上有一个如此有趣的故事时，他推翻了他的表亲，他夺取了王冠，他是篡位者，他缺乏安全感，他的儿子后来成为了伟大的英雄国王。为什么我们对亨利四世了解不多？这很有趣，因为在《亨利四世》剧中，我的意思是，他是一个相当阴暗的人物。他非常疲惫，他忧心忡忡。我的意思是，
almost kind of irrelevant to all the great drama of the sweep and churn of rebellion that is convulsing England. And you're right that by and large, he hasn't been the subject of many biographies. So the classic academic study by Chris Given-Wilson. Given-Wilson says in that, that he's the most neglected of England's late medieval monarchs. I think you could almost say he was the most neglected of all England's monarchs. But the interesting thing is that he seems to be having a bit of a moment right now. So as well as given Wilson's amazing biography, there's one by Ian Mortimer, which is very good, very readable. And there's a brilliant paired biography of Richard II and Henry IV by Helen Castor that is coming out next month, which I've had a chance
几乎与席卷英格兰的叛乱的巨大戏剧性和动荡无关。你是对的，总的来说，他并没有成为许多传记的主题。所以克里斯·吉文-威尔逊（Chris Given-Wilson）的经典学术研究。吉文-威尔逊在书中说，他是英格兰中世纪晚期君主中最被忽视的一位。我想你几乎可以说他是英格兰所有君主中最被忽视的一位。但有趣的是，他现在似乎正处于一个受关注的时刻。所以除了吉文-威尔逊那本了不起的传记外，还有伊恩·莫蒂默（Ian Mortimer）写的一本，非常好，非常易读。还有海伦·卡斯托（Helen Castor）写的一本关于理查二世和亨利四世的精彩对传，下个月就要出版了，我有机会
to read, which is really good. So if you're interested in this, that's unmissable. And I think that all these books have fixed on the fact that obviously Shakespeare did as well, that actually the story of the reign is really dramatic. But more than that, he himself is actually a much more interesting figure than people might think. So as you said, I mean, the story of his coming to power is incredible. He launches an invasion from France and topples a king. And the previous monarch to do that was William the Conqueror. And he then eliminates a king. He has to kill Richard II. So there are shades of Cromwell as well as of kind of earlier medieval regicides there, as we'll see, because it opens up a kind of constitutional can of worms.
读了，真的很好。所以如果你对这个感兴趣，那是不容错过的。我认为所有这些书都聚焦于这样一个事实，即莎士比亚显然也做到了，实际上他的统治故事确实非常戏剧化。但不仅如此，他本人实际上是一个比人们想象中更有趣的人物。所以正如你所说，我的意思是，他掌权的故事令人难以置信。他从法国发动入侵并推翻了一位国王。而上一个那样做的君主是威廉征服者。然后他消灭了一位国王。他不得不杀死理查二世。所以正如我们将要看到的，那里既有克伦威尔的影子，也有早期中世纪弑君者的影子，因为它打开了一个宪法上的潘多拉魔盒。
But more than that, I think in and of himself, he's a very, very impressive figure. So before he comes to power, he's absolutely kind of fated as England's great model of chivalry. He's the most impressive knight, the most celebrated knight in England. And I think even as king, because of the circumstances in which he comes to power, he has a very troubled reign. And I think it would have destroyed most other men. So Helen Castor in her book describes his grip on power throughout his reign as being white knuckled. There's a sense he's clinging on for his bare life, but he comes through it. And although there are lots of people who hate him, who think that the circumstances of his coming to power essentially mean that he's
但不仅如此，我认为他本身就是一个非常、非常令人印象深刻的人物。所以在掌权之前，他绝对被誉为英格兰的骑士精神典范。他是英格兰最令人印象深刻的骑士，最著名的骑士。而且我认为即使作为国王，由于他掌权时的环境，他的统治也非常艰难。我认为这会摧毁大多数其他人。所以海伦·卡斯托在她的书中描述他在整个统治期间对权力的掌控是“白手起家”般的紧张。有一种他为了生存而死死抓住的感觉，但他挺过来了。尽管有很多人恨他，认为他掌权的环境本质上意味着他是
illegitimate, there are others who really think, wow, this is an impressive guy. So there's the prior of a monastery in Kenilworth who's a bittery on him. Few were his equal, many were his followers and never was he defeated in battle. And that's, I think, not unfair. It says it all. I mean, I think for people who admire great politicians, people who are adept at gaining and wielding power and do it with a kind of natural aptitude he's a he's a great model right i mean he's a really impressive in a very dangerous world in a very difficult situation he plays his cards really well helen castor in her her new book the eagle in the heart sums it up really well she's she says henry had everything richard lacked
非法的，但也有其他人真的认为，哇，这是一个令人印象深刻的家伙。所以凯尼尔沃思（Kenilworth）的一位修道院院长对他评价很高。很少有人能与他匹敌，许多人是他的追随者，他在战斗中从未被击败。我认为这并不夸张。这说明了一切。我的意思是，我认为对于那些钦佩伟大政治家的人来说，那些善于获得和运用权力并以一种天生的天赋做到这一点的人，他是一个伟大的榜样，对吧？我的意思是，他在一个非常危险的世界里，在一个非常困难的情况下，他真的很令人印象深刻，他把牌打得很好。海伦·卡斯托在她她的新书《鹰在心中》（The Eagle in the Heart）中总结得非常好，她说亨利拥有理查所缺乏的一切，
all the qualities of a sovereign bar one birthright right and in her book yeah she teases out the fact that this inevitably generates a sense of tension between henry and richard and that they are cousins and they are the only people of the the english royal family of the same age so henry's kind of three months younger than richard and they don't actually meet one another until they're about five or six but there there is tension there from the beginning. Well, let's remind ourselves where we are, Tom. So in England at the end of the 14th century, Henry was born in 1367. He is three months younger than Richard II. People who remember our Hundred Years War series remember Edward III. Richard II is his young successor. He's a boy when he becomes king and grandson yes so edward the third i mean edward the third has lots of children he has five sons
除了一个品质：与生俱来的权利，对吧？在她的书中，是的，她梳理了这样一个事实，即这不可避免地在亨利和理查之间产生了紧张感，他们是表亲，他们是英国王室中同龄的仅有的人，所以亨利比理查小三个月，他们实际上直到五六岁才见面，但从一开始就有紧张感。好吧，让我们提醒自己我们身处何处，汤姆。在14世纪末的英格兰，亨利出生于1367年。他比理查二世小三个月。记得我们《百年战争》系列的听众会记得爱德华三世。理查二世是他年轻的继任者。他成为国王时还是个男孩，是的，孙子，所以爱德华三世，我的意思是，爱德华三世有很多孩子，他有五个儿子，
but there are three sons for our purposes the purposes of this story for listeners to keep in mind so he has his best known son edward the black prince the winner of poitier the great model of chivalry and richard the second is the Prince's son. Then his second son is a guy called Lionel, who's the Duke of Clarence. And he has a daughter, not a son. And this daughter, Philippa, marries a very distinguished nobleman called Edmund Mortimer, who is the Earl of March. And so, Dominic, he has a great tranche of lands and the border between Wales and England. So very much your stamping ground. My neck of the woods.
但为了我们的目的，为了这个故事的目的，为了让听众记住，有三个儿子：他最著名的儿子爱德华黑太子，普瓦捷战役的胜利者，骑士精神的伟大典范，而理查二世是黑太子的儿子。然后他的第二个儿子是一个叫莱昂内尔的人，他是克拉伦斯公爵。他有一个女儿，而不是儿子。这个女儿，菲利帕，嫁给了一位非常杰出的贵族，名叫埃德蒙·莫蒂默，他是马奇伯爵。所以，多米尼克，他在威尔士和英格兰的边界拥有大片土地。所以非常像是你的地盘。我的地盘。
Yeah. Yeah. You would have been his banner man. Or he would have been mine. I don't think so. Because of course, you know, he's married to the granddaughter of a king. Yeah. Okay.
是的。是的。你本来会是他的旗手。或者他会是我的。我不这么认为。因为当然，你知道，他娶了一位国王的孙女。是的。好吧。
Fine, fine, fine, fine. And they have two sons. The elder is called Roger and the younger, confusingly, is called Edmund. And Roger is seven years younger than Richard and Henry. So he is ahead of Henry, it might seem, in the chain of succession, except for the fact that Edward III in 1376 had specified that his descendants via the female line shouldn't inherit the throne. So that then means that Henry, who is the son of the third son of Edward III, John of Gaunt, the Duke of Lancaster. I mean, he's kind of behind John of Gaunt and behind Richard in the line of succession.
好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧。他们有两个儿子。长子叫罗杰，次子，令人困惑的是，叫埃德蒙。罗杰比理查和亨利小七岁。所以他似乎在继承顺序上领先于亨利，除了这样一个事实：爱德华三世在1376年曾规定，他的后代不能通过女性血统继承王位。所以这意味着亨利，作为爱德华三世的第三个儿子冈特的约翰（兰开斯特公爵）的儿子。我的意思是，他在继承顺序上排在冈特的约翰之后，排在理查之后。
But given that John of Gaunt's older, that means that Richard and Henry are natural. They're not rivals, but there's a kind of tension there, right? Yeah. So when Edward III dies, John of Gaunt effectively rules as regent. So people who listen to our episodes on Richard II will remember that he's a very, very impressive, controversial figure. And effectively, it means, as you say, Henry grows up kind of third in line to the throne. And so I think that that focuses why there's an inherent awkwardness between Richard and Henry. But I think it's also down to the fact that Henry, as this model of chivalry, he has the admiration, not just of people in England, but of people across Europe in a way that Richard doesn't. Richard, despite being the son of the Black Prince, he's not a model of chivalry.
但考虑到冈特的约翰年长，这意味着理查和亨利是自然的。他们不是竞争对手，但有一种紧张感，对吧？是的。所以当爱德华三世去世时，冈特的约翰实际上作为摄政王统治。所以听过我们关于理查二世剧集的听众会记得，他是一个非常、非常令人印象深刻、有争议的人物。实际上，这意味着，正如你所说，亨利成长过程中在继承顺序上排在第三位。所以我认为这聚焦了为什么理查和亨利之间存在内在的尴尬。但我认为这也归结于这样一个事实：亨利作为骑士精神的典范，他不仅受到英格兰人的钦佩，而且受到全欧洲人的钦佩，这是理查所没有的。理查，尽管是黑太子的儿子，但他不是骑士精神的典范。
He's not a man of action. He's not galloping around doing heroic things. He's understandably jealous of his cousin for having the kind of the glamour. So, I mean, just a very brief synopsis of how Henry cuts a dash in late 14th century Europe. So his great stunt is that in 1390, he goes and attends the most famous tournament of the age, which is held just outside Calais at a place called Saint-Anglevert. And it is hosted by probably the most famous knight in Christendom, close contemporary of Henry's. And this is a guy called Jean Lemagre, who is better known as Boussico. And this is a figure that we'll be meeting throughout our story. And he is one of three champions who have summoned a challenge to everybody to come and see if they can you know match them in in a tournament and henry leads a retinue of english champions
他不是一个行动派。他不是在四处奔波做英雄事迹。他理所当然地嫉妒他的表亲拥有那种魅力。所以，我的意思是，关于亨利如何在14世纪末的欧洲大放异彩的简短概要。所以他伟大的壮举是，在1390年，他去参加了那个时代最著名的锦标赛，该锦标赛在加来郊外一个叫圣昂格尔韦尔（Saint-Anglevert）的地方举行。它由可能是基督教世界最著名的骑士、亨利的同时代人主持。这是一个叫让·勒迈格（Jean Lemagre）的人，他更广为人知的名字是布西科（Boussico）。这是我们在整个故事中会遇到的一个人物。他是三位冠军之一，他们向所有人发出了挑战，来看看他们是否能在锦标赛中与他们匹敌，亨利带领着一群英格兰冠军，
and among this retinue of champions there is the son of the earl of northumberland called harry percy who has the nickname hot spur yeah. So they go out. They all perform very creditably. Henry has 10 goes in the lists against Boussico. Tremendous. They get on very well. Boussico invites him on a crusade. Henry does go on a crusade. He goes to the Baltic to fight the pagans,
在这群冠军中，有诺森伯兰伯爵的儿子，名叫哈里·珀西，他有个绰号叫“热刺”（Hotspur）。是的。所以他们出发了。他们都表现得非常出色。亨利在比武中与布西科交手了10次。太棒了。他们相处得很好。布西科邀请他去参加十字军东征。亨利确实去参加了十字军东征。他去了波罗的海去对抗异教徒，
the pagan Lithuanians. He goes to Jerusalem. He gets given an ostrich in Prague he gets given a galley by the Venetians, he ends up going to the Holy Land Richard the Lionheart Edward I, they are both kings who had been to the Holy Land
异教徒立陶宛人。他去了耶路撒冷。他在布拉格得到了一只鸵鸟，他从威尼斯人那里得到了一艘桨帆船，他最终去了圣地。理查狮心王、爱德华一世，他们都是去过圣地的国王，
but neither of them had actually got to Jerusalem Henry does get into Jerusalem itself, he goes and visits the Holy City And he's got a leopard he's got a parrot. He's got a parrot. He's got a leopard. He's got a parrot. He's got his ostrich. I mean, it's all very, very glamorous. And it's unsurprisingly that back in England, people just think this is brilliant. I mean, he's an absolute hero. So John Gower, who is a great poet alongside Geoffrey Chaucer, he has this poem, Confessio Amantis, and he dedicated it to Richard
但他们两人实际上都没有到达耶路撒冷。亨利确实进入了耶路撒冷本身，他去参观了圣城。他有一只豹子，他有一只鹦鹉。他有一只鹦鹉。他有一只豹子。他有一只鹦鹉。他有他的鸵鸟。我的意思是，这一切都非常、非常迷人。毫不奇怪，在英格兰，人们只是认为这太棒了。我的意思是，他是一个绝对的英雄。所以约翰·高尔（John Gower），他是与杰弗里·乔叟齐名的伟大诗人，他有这首诗《情人忏悔录》（Confessio Amantis），他把它献给了理查
II. But when Henry comes back, he scrubs this dedication and dedicates it to Henry of Lancaster instead. Henry of Lancaster, the high God has proclaimed him full of knighthood and all grace. So you can imagine that slightly annoying Richard II. Richard, as we discussed before, is a man of great sensitivity, but also one of great vindictiveness. He's a hater, isn't he, Richard? He is a hater. And he feels resentment of his cousin's tremendous exploits and all of that stuff, which presumably for any king would show you up, right?
二世。但当亨利回来时，他删除了这个献词，转而把它献给了兰开斯特的亨利。兰开斯特的亨利，伟大的上帝宣称他充满了骑士精神和所有的恩典。所以你可以想象这让理查二世稍微有点恼火。理查，正如我们之前讨论的那样，是一个非常敏感的人，但也是一个非常记仇的人。他是个“仇恨者”，不是吗，理查？他是个仇恨者。他对他表亲的巨大功绩和所有这些事情感到怨恨，这对于任何国王来说都会让你显得相形见绌，对吧？
Because you're not a martial man, and you're anxious that you're not seen in the same light right and i mean people who heard our episode on the hundred years war edward iii the reason edward iii is seen as a great king is because he's very good at all the things that the nobility love so fighting tournaments all that kind of stuff which henry is as well and richard simply't. And so it's unsurprising that towards the end of his reign, Richard really starts to try and kind of downgrade Henry, to try and bump him off the line of succession. So in 1386, he announces that his heir is Roger Mortimer, so the son of Philippa, the daughter of Lionel. So that is to mess up the line of succession
因为你不是一个尚武的人，而且你担心自己没有被以同样的眼光看待，对吧？我的意思是，听过我们《百年战争》剧集的人知道，爱德华三世之所以被视为伟大的国王，是因为他非常擅长贵族们喜欢的所有事情，比如战斗、锦标赛，所有这些事情，亨利也是如此，而理查根本不是。所以毫不奇怪，在他统治末期，理查真的开始试图贬低亨利，试图把他从继承顺序中挤掉。所以1386年，他宣布他的继承人是罗杰·莫蒂默，也就是莱昂内尔的女儿菲利帕的儿子。所以这打乱了爱德华三世所规定的继承顺序。
that Edward III had decreed. So Roger is then killed in Ireland in 1398 and he leaves a seven-year-old son, Edmund. So the question now is, is Edmund Richard II's heir or is John of Gaunt and Henry? It's kind of up for grabs. But just to make absolutely certain that it's going to be the young Edmund, Richard then in 1398 exiles Henry
所以罗杰后来于1398年在爱尔兰被杀，他留下了一个七岁的儿子埃德蒙。所以现在的问题是，埃德蒙是理查二世的继承人，还是冈特的约翰和亨利？这有点悬而未决。但为了确保一定是年轻的埃德蒙，理查随后在1398年流放了亨利
for 10 years. And the following year when John of Gaunt dies, the question then is, will the exiled Henry be allowed to come back and take over his lands and inherit John of Gaunt's title of Duke of Lancaster. And Richard says, no, he's going to take over all of Henry's lands. And he doesn't award the stewardship of England, which has been held by the House of Lancaster for a century to Henry. And basically he strips him of everything. And it's this that precipitates Henry's return from exile. He lands at Ravenspur just down the Humber from Hull. And within a few months, Richard has been abandoned by his men. He's been captured, he's been deposed, and he ends up being killed.
10年。第二年，当冈特的约翰去世时，问题就变成了，流亡的亨利是否会被允许回来接管他的土地并继承冈特的约翰的兰开斯特公爵头衔。理查说，不，他要接管亨利所有的土地。而且他没有把由兰开斯特家族持有一个世纪的英格兰管家职位授予亨利。基本上他剥夺了他的一切。正是这一点促使亨利从流亡中归来。他在赫尔附近的雷文斯普尔（Ravenspur）登陆。几个月内，理查就被他的人民抛弃了。他被俘虏，被废黜，最终被杀。
And Henry obviously does this for personal reasons. When he lands, he says, I'm coming back to reclaim my lands. I'm doing it to uphold the laws of succession. And this is widely accepted because what Richard has done, it's not just an attack on Henry himself, but on the entire basis of succession that underpins the way that England is organized. So all the nobility, when they see what Richard has done, is thinking, well, this could happen to us. This is terrifying.
亨利显然是出于个人原因这样做。当他登陆时，他说，我回来是为了收回我的土地。我这样做是为了维护继承法。这被广泛接受，因为理查所做的事情，不仅是对亨利本人的攻击，而且是对支撑英格兰组织方式的整个继承基础的攻击。所以所有的贵族，当他们看到理查所做的事情时，都在想，好吧，这可能会发生在我们身上。这太可怕了。
So when Henry takes over, I mean, Tom, you always like to make this point about an anointed king. You know, it's very special. It's a terrible thing to topple an anointed king, all of that kind of thing. And Shakespeare plays with that in Henry IV, parts one and two. But do you think that among the elite, people think
所以当亨利接管时，我的意思是，汤姆，你总是喜欢提出关于受膏国王的观点。你知道，这非常特别。推翻一位受膏国王是一件可怕的事情，所有这些事情。莎士比亚在《亨利四世（上篇）》和《下篇》中对此进行了演绎。但你认为在精英阶层中，人们认为
Henry's in a very difficult position, of course, but he's probably done the right thing. Richard had to go. We don't like it, maybe, but we just have to live with it. Yes. I mean, most of them do. Most of the nobility swing behind him. As I said, they're worried that they don't want their own lands being confiscated. Yeah, Richard's out of control. They feel that Richard is essentially instituting a tyranny, a despotism. And the family that particularly swing behind Henry are the Percys, who are the great power in Northumberland, the guardians of the Northern Marches against the Scots. But there's also a sense in which Henry is reaching out beyond the nobility to the people. And when he becomes king, he does it not by right of succession, but by
亨利处于一个非常困难的位置，当然，但他可能做了正确的事情。理查必须走。我们可能不喜欢它，但我们只能接受它。是的。我的意思是，他们中的大多数人确实如此。大多数贵族转向支持他。正如我所说，他们担心他们不想自己的土地被没收。是的，理查失控了。他们觉得理查本质上是在建立一种暴政、一种专制。而特别转向支持亨利的家族是珀西家族，他们是诺森伯兰的强大力量，是反对苏格兰人的北部边境的守护者。但亨利也在某种程度上超越了贵族，向人民伸出了援手。当他成为国王时，他不是通过继承权，而是通过
election. So there's a sense almost that he is, I mean, I think that the closest that you get in the whole of medieval English history to a prime minister coming in and replacing a kind of clapped out administration. Right. The sense of election that Henry has been chosen is really, really important. And that's why Henry, unlike any other English king, really has to work hard on the propaganda to kind of justify how and why he's become king. He pulls out all the stops. He promulgates prophecies by Merlin that he's going to be a great king. There's a tremendous story that is told by a Welsh priest called Adam of Arsk, who we'll be meeting throughout the story, who says that there was a greyhound who
选举。所以几乎有一种感觉，他，我的意思是，我认为在整个英国中世纪历史上，你所能得到的最接近于一位首相上台并取代一个破旧政府的情况。对。亨利被选中的选举感真的、非常重要。这就是为什么亨利，不像任何其他英国国王，真的必须在宣传上下功夫，以证明他如何以及为什么成为国王。他竭尽全力。他颁布了梅林的预言，说他将成为一位伟大的国王。有一位威尔士牧师叫亚当·阿斯克（Adam of Arsk），我们将在整个故事中遇到他，他讲述了一个了不起的故事，他说有一只灰狗，
was a bit like the octopus in the World Cup. You can kind of choose winners. This greyhound had abandoned a duke who was about to die, goes to Richard, and then when choose winners yeah this greyhound had abandoned a duke who was about to die goes to richard and then when henry comes the greyhound abandons richard and goes to henry you know absolutely gaze up at him with great big brown eyes full of love um and then subsequently when henry meets richard uh the greyhound completely ignores richard can't even remember him and this is an infallible proof that Henry has been chosen to be king. Right. And that story sounds like it's definitely true, doesn't it?
有点像世界杯里的章鱼。你可以选择赢家。这只灰狗抛弃了一位即将死去的公爵，走向理查，然后当亨利来的时候，这只灰狗抛弃了理查，走向亨利，你知道，绝对是用充满爱的大棕色眼睛凝视着他，嗯，然后随后当亨利见到理查时，这只灰狗完全无视理查，甚至记不住他，这是亨利被选为国王的绝对证据。对。那个故事听起来绝对是真的，不是吗？
Completely. Who would question that? Completely. But I mean, it's definitely the case that when Henry ends up capturing Richard, they process into London. Henry is cheered. He's greeted as a kind of conquering hero. And when he's elected king, he plays it
完全是。谁会质疑那个？完全是。但我的意思是，当亨利最终俘虏理查时，他们进入伦敦，这绝对是事实。亨利受到欢呼。他被当作一种征服英雄来迎接。当他被选为国王时，他表现得
very, very well. And he rises from his seat and he makes the sign of the cross and he commends himself to God. And he delivers his claim, not in French, not in Latin, but in English. And Chris Gibbon Wilson in his biography says, you know, this is the first declaration by a king in the English tongue. It's the equivalent of the prime minister standing outside Downing Street and making his first address to the nation. But doing it in English is sending a message that he's not going to be as remote and as autocratic and as Frenchified as Richard. Is that what it's basically saying? I think it is. But I think it's also saying, you know, that he is the people's king.
非常、非常好。他从座位上站起来，画了一个十字，并把自己托付给上帝。他提出了他的主张，不是用法语，不是用拉丁语，而是用英语。克里斯·吉文-威尔逊在他的传记中说，你知道，这是国王第一次用英语发表声明。这相当于首相站在唐宁街外发表对国家的第一次演讲。但用英语做这件事是在传达一个信息，即他不会像理查那样疏远、专制和法国化。这就是他基本上想说的吗？我想是的。但我认为他也在说，你知道，他是人民的国王。
Right. Because this matters in a way that it doesn't. It hadn't for any previous king, because in a way, public enthusiasm for him, both among the nobility, but also among the great mass of the English people, is the key to his legitimacy. It's the only source of legitimacy that he has, because he can't rely on the rules of succession because there's this problem that there's this eight-year-old Edmund, the son of Roger, the Earl of March. I mean, he's lurking around. And so Henry grabs him and puts him in a kind of silken imprisonment in Windsor. But he can't harp on his right to the succession. So it has to be
对。因为这很重要，以一种它以前对任何国王都不重要的方式，因为在某种程度上，公众对他的热情，无论是在贵族中，还是在广大英国人民中，都是他合法性的关键。这是他拥有的唯一合法性来源，因为他不能依赖继承规则，因为存在这样一个问题，即有一个八岁的埃德蒙，罗杰的儿子，马奇伯爵。我的意思是，他潜伏在周围。所以亨利抓住了他，把他关进了温莎城堡的一种丝绸般的监禁中。但他不能喋喋不休地谈论他的继承权。所以它必须
about election. And of course, the other thing that it requires him to do is really, really go in hard, condemning Richard as a kind of tyrant. And so when he becomes king, again, very like a kind of prime minister, he makes it absolutely clear and he makes it a public proclamation that he's going to respect property rights and he's going to respect the will of the people. So in a sense, you know, as king, he is the servant of the people and this is a very very novel tone you haven't had this before i mean you're still doing a great job of selling him actually to the listeners i would imagine well i he's in an incredibly invidious position because yeah you know this
关于选举。当然，另一件事是要求他真正地、真正地强硬起来，谴责理查是一种暴君。所以当他成为国王时，再次非常像一位首相，他非常明确地表示，并公开宣布他将尊重财产权，他将尊重人民的意愿。所以从某种意义上说，你知道，作为国王，他是人民的仆人，这是一种非常、非常新颖的基调，你以前没有过这种情况。我的意思是，你实际上还在为听众推销他。好吧，我，他处于一个极其令人反感的境地，因为是的，你知道这
isn't the kind of thing that a king should have to do a king ascends by by right but do you know what tom in a way i mean a lot of people will bridle at this comparison but we did a podcast about the princes in the tower richard iii was in a really tough position then and he had to kill his uh nephews and you know that some people associated with this podcast commend him for that but henry iv was in a similarly difficult position he was it was it was like win or bust yeah if he if he didn't topple richard and basically kill him and take the throne then he might as well go and live in a hut back in the baltic or something well yes and i think that had henry been toppled he would be remembered as a kind of richard the third yeah not just a usurper but a failure yeah i agree with you he would have been regarded as a failure but of course he isn't a failure. The only thing is he's promising this great new start,
不是国王应该做的事情，国王通过权利登基，但你知道吗，汤姆，在某种程度上，我的意思是很多人会对这种比较感到愤怒，但我们做了一个关于塔中王子的播客，理查三世当时处于一个非常艰难的境地，他不得不杀死他的侄子们，你知道有些人与这个播客有关的人称赞他这样做，但亨利四世处于一个同样困难的境地，他，这就像赢或输，是的，如果他不推翻理查并基本上杀死他并夺取王位，那么他不如回到波罗的海住在一个小屋里什么的。好吧，是的，我认为如果亨利被推翻，他会被记住为一种理查三世，是的，不仅仅是一个篡位者，而且是一个失败者，是的，我同意你的看法，他会被视为一个失败者。唯一的问题是他承诺了一个伟大的新开始，
but as we know with any incoming prime minister, to use your analogy, there's no such thing really as a clean break, is there? So is he wrestling with the same problems that Richard was, basically? He is, but there are also advantages to this. So again, for comparison with the prime minister, one of the things that is working to Henry's advantage is the fact that by this stage, England is basically the most centralized kingdom in Europe, meaning in turn that it's the most manageable. And so you effectively have a kind of cadre of civil servants who are working in offices that are based in Westminster,
但正如我们所知，对于任何即将上任的首相，用你的类比，没有所谓的彻底决裂，不是吗？所以他是在处理理查面临的同样问题吗，基本上？他是，但这样做也有优势。所以再次与首相进行比较，亨利的一个优势是，在这个阶段，英格兰基本上是欧洲最集中的王国，这意味着它也是最易于管理的。所以你实际上拥有一批在威斯敏斯特办公的公务员，
the chancery, the exchequer, these frameworks of government that government today has essentially inherited from this period. And so as a result, despite all the convulsions, the toppling of Richard II, the coming to power of Henry IV, government goes on as it does today. One government falls, another government comes in, but the civil service continues. So that's a positive. But as you say, he's essentially inherited the problems that Richard II was facing. How do you deal with financial shortfall? Richard II had burned through money. Parliament was very reluctant to vote him money. And Henry IV has the problem that people believe that he has promised there will be no more tax rises.
大法官法庭、财政部，这些政府框架是当今政府基本上从这一时期继承下来的。所以结果是，尽管有所有的动荡、理查二世的倒台、亨利四世的掌权，政府就像今天一样继续运作。一个政府倒台，另一个政府上台，但公务员制度继续存在。所以这是一个积极因素。但正如你所说，他基本上继承了理查二世面临的问题。你如何处理财政短缺？理查二世花光了钱。议会非常不情愿投票给他钱。而亨利四世面临的问题是，人们相信他已经承诺不会再有加税。
So, I mean, again, very familiar. This is always the way with incoming prime ministers. Absolutely. Exactly. So he's seen as having made as part of his pitch that there will be no tax rises. And in fact, shortly after he's crowned in Somerset, there's a tax collector who's beaten to death because, and I'll quote, his demands were contrary to the promise, excusing them from such payments, which the king had made to them at the time of his happy return.
所以，我的意思是，再次，非常熟悉。这总是即将上任的首相的方式。绝对。完全正确。所以他被视为作为他推销的一部分，承诺不会有加税。事实上，在他加冕后不久，在萨默塞特，有一名收税员被殴打致死，因为，我引用一下，“他的要求违背了国王在他快乐归来时向他们做出的免除此类付款的承诺。”
So people across England are saying, brilliant, we've got this new king. We don't have to pay taxes. It's fantastic. You know, but this is a real problem for Henry because he really needs money. I mean, he's king now. There's also the problem that he needs to keep the Percys in particular on board. If he loses them, he's in real trouble. And there's also the fact that England is surrounded by enemies.
所以全英格兰的人都在说，太棒了，我们有了这位新国王。我们不必纳税。这太棒了。你知道，但这对亨利来说是一个真正的问题，因为他真的需要钱。我的意思是，他现在是国王了。还有一个问题是，他需要特别让珀西家族留在船上。如果他失去了他们，他就真的有麻烦了。而且还有一个事实是，英格兰被敌人包围了。
So officially still at war with France, but there are also enemies actually on the island of Britain. So there are the Scots, the Weasel Scots, as Shakespeare describes them in Henry V, always sniffing out trouble in England. And there's also hints of trouble in Wales, which has been under English rule for a century. So these are all problems. But I think the biggest problem, which we've already hinted at, is that having come to power as a usurper, Henry then has to rule as a regicide because with the deposition of Richard II, he's bundled him off to one of the great Lancastrian castles, Pontefract,
所以官方仍然与法国处于战争状态，但实际上在不列颠岛上也有敌人。所以有苏格兰人，正如莎士比亚在《亨利五世》中所描述的那样，狡猾的苏格兰人，总是嗅出英格兰的麻烦。而且还有威尔士麻烦的迹象，威尔士已经处于英格兰统治下一个世纪了。所以这些都是问题。但我认为最大的问题，我们已经暗示过了，是作为篡位者掌权后，亨利随后必须作为弑君者统治，因为随着理查二世的废黜，他把他捆绑到了兰开斯特最伟大的城堡之一，庞特弗拉克特（Pontefract），
and wants to just basically leave him there. But there are conspiracies. There are people trying to overthrow Henry, bring back Richard II. And there's one in particular, it's called the Epiphany Rising because it happens in the season of Epiphany. And Henry treats this very, very brutally, even though he has a reputation for clemency. He can't afford to show any mercy here. So our friend Adam of Ask, the Welsh chaplain, he describes that he was in London at the time after the execution of all the conspirators in this. And he describes seeing that their bodies being carried through London,
并想基本上把他留在那里。但有阴谋。有人试图推翻亨利，带回理查二世。有一个特别的，它被称为“主显节起义”（Epiphany Rising），因为它发生在主显节期间。亨利对此处理得非常、非常残酷，尽管他以宽大为怀而闻名。他在这里负担不起表现出任何仁慈。所以我们的朋友亚当·阿斯克，那位威尔士牧师，他描述说，在所有阴谋者被处决后，他当时在伦敦。他描述看到他们的尸体被运过伦敦，
chopped up like the carcasses of beasts killed in the chase, partly in sacks and partly on poles slung across pairs of men's shoulders. That's sending a message, Tom. Well, sending a message, but I mean, essentially sending a message that his regime is pretty unstable.
像在狩猎中被杀的野兽尸体一样被剁碎，部分装在麻袋里，部分挂在横跨在两人肩膀上的杆子上。那是在传达一个信息，汤姆。好吧，传达一个信息，但我的意思是，基本上是在传达一个信息，即他的政权相当不稳定。
And so the question is, as a usurper and a regicide, how is Henry going to cope with all the challenges that are clearly coming his way? And just before we go to the break, one quick question. If I met Henry IV at this point, what's he like? I mean, you've said he's very glamorous. He's obviously very brave. He's a bit of an alpha male because of all the tournaments and the crusades and stuff. But you then said a reputation for clemency. So he's a man that other people admire. He is a man who other people admire. Yes. He's, he's also very literate. He's
所以问题是，作为一个篡位者和弑君者，亨利将如何应对显然会向他袭来的所有挑战？在休息之前，一个快速的问题。如果我此时见到亨利四世，他是什么样的人？我的意思是，你说他非常迷人。他显然非常勇敢。因为所有的锦标赛和十字军东征什么的，他有点像个阿尔法男性。但你随后说他有宽大为怀的名声。所以他是一个其他人钦佩的人。他是一个其他人钦佩的人。是的。他，他也非常有文化。他
very smart. He's deeply Christian. He thinks very profoundly about his faith. So in all kinds of ways, he's admirable. But I think his tragedy is that all these qualities, which had helped to bring him to the throne after he's come to the throne and after he's been responsible for the murder of Richard II, people don't believe them anymore. And he's in a desperate struggle to stop the entire situation, as we will see, from collapsing. What a cliffhanger. So come back after the break to see if he can stave off disaster. I'm Marina Hyde.
非常聪明。他是一个虔诚的基督徒。他非常深刻地思考他的信仰。所以从各方面来看，他是令人钦佩的。但我认为他的悲剧在于，所有这些在他掌权后帮助他登上王位，在他掌权后，在他对理查二世的谋杀负责后，人们不再相信它们了。他正处于一场绝望的斗争中，以阻止整个局势，正如我们将要看到的，崩溃。多么悬念。所以休息后回来看看他是否能避免灾难。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
我是理查·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Thou makes me sad and makes me sin in envy that my lord Northumberland should be the father to so blessed a son, a son who is the theme of honour's tongue, amongst a grove the very straightest plant, who is sweet fortune's minion and a pride, whilst I, by looking on the praise of him, see riot and dishonour stain the brow of my young harry oh that it could be proof that some night-tripping fairy had exchanged in cradle clothes our children where they lay and called mine percy his plantagenet then would i have his harry and he mine so tom we were talking about
和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。“你让我悲伤，让我因嫉妒而犯罪，因为我的诺森伯兰勋爵竟然是如此有福之子的父亲，一个作为荣誉之舌主题的儿子，在树林中最挺拔的植物，他是幸运女神的宠儿和骄傲，而我，看着对他的赞美，看到放荡和不光彩玷污了我年轻哈里的额头，哦，如果能证明某个夜间出没的仙女在摇篮里交换了我们的孩子，把我的珀西称为他的金雀花，那么我就会有他的哈里，他有我的。”所以汤姆，我们当时在谈论
henry the fourth uh shakespeare's great plays parts one and two that's at the beginning that's the character we've been talking about king henry the fourth and he is riffing on one of the great themes of the play so this is the contrast between his own son prince hal who is this hard drinking jape lovingtrel. A fan of riot and dishonour. Riot and dishonour, yeah. The kind of person who would be being hurled out of nightclubs today and just disgracing himself in the gutter. That's Prince Hal.
亨利四世，莎士比亚伟大的剧作《上篇》和《下篇》，那是开头，那是我们一直在谈论的角色，亨利四世国王，他正在即兴发挥剧中的伟大主题之一。所以这是他自己的儿子哈尔王子与他自己的对比，哈尔王子是一个酗酒、喜欢恶作剧的流浪汉。一个放荡和不光彩的粉丝。放荡和不光彩，是的。那种今天会被赶出夜总会并在阴沟里丢脸的人。那就是哈尔王子。
And parallel to him is another Harry. You've mentioned him already. Harry Hotspur, the son of Northumberland, the great magnate in the north of England. And Hotspur is everything that Hal isn't. Hotspur is dutiful, serious. He's incredibly brave. He fights like a demon.
与他并列的是另一个哈里。你已经提到过他了。哈里·霍茨珀，诺森伯兰伯爵之子，英格兰北部的大权贵。霍茨珀拥有哈尔所没有的一切。霍茨珀尽职尽责，严肃认真。他极其勇敢。他打起仗来像个恶魔。
He's not like drinking with a load of wenches and sort of ladies of the night down in the docks of London or whatever. He's rushing around attacking Scots and being heroic and generally being a massive lad. And is this true? So the whole thing depends in Shakespeare on Hotspur and Prince Hal being contemporaries, a bit like Richard II and Henry. This is the tension. But this isn't true because, as we said, Hotspur had actually accompanied
他不像哈尔那样在伦敦码头和一群妓女或夜店女郎厮混。他四处奔波，攻击苏格兰人，表现得英勇无畏，总的来说是个了不起的汉子。这是真的吗？在莎士比亚的剧作中，整个故事都建立在霍茨珀和哈尔王子是同龄人的基础上，有点像理查二世和亨利的关系。这就是张力所在。但这并非事实，因为正如我们所说，霍茨珀实际上曾陪伴
the future Henry IV to this great tournament in France when they were young men. So he's a contemporary of the king. In fact, he's three years older than the king. He's not a contemporary of Prince Hal. But I think the thing about Hotspur for Henry IV, and I think this is something that Shakespeare possibly has picked up on, is that Hotspur is a reminder to Henry IV of kind of how fun it was not to be a king. Hotspur is a reminder to Henry of the man that he was before he usurped the throne. He has fun in The Chimes at Midnight. He's got a kind of very groovy Beatles hairstyle. He's rushing around.
未来的亨利四世在他们年轻时参加了法国的那场盛大锦标赛。所以他是国王的同龄人。事实上，他比国王大三岁。他不是哈尔王子的同龄人。但我认为，对于亨利四世来说，霍茨珀之所以重要——我想这也是莎士比亚可能捕捉到的——是因为霍茨珀提醒了亨利四世，不用当国王是多么有趣。霍茨珀提醒了亨利，他在篡位之前是什么样的人。在《午夜钟声》里他玩得很开心。他留着那种非常时髦的披头士发型。他四处奔波。
He's ha-ha-ha, all this kind of thing, leather jerking. He's rushing around. He's ha ha ha. All this kind of thing. Leather jerking. It's all brilliant. Great fun. He would totally wear a gilet. Oh, completely. I mean, effectively, he does wear a gilet in Times Midnight. But yes, he'd be a massive man for a gilet.
他哈哈大笑，诸如此类，穿着皮夹克。他四处奔波。他哈哈大笑。所有这些。皮夹克。真是太棒了。非常有趣。他绝对会穿一件背心。哦，完全会。我的意思是，实际上他在《午夜钟声》里确实穿了背心。但没错，他绝对是个穿背心的狂热爱好者。
You know what he'd love? He'd love rugby. He'd love going to rugby. Cheering on England at Murrayfield. He'd be all over that. He's a man man his dad's got a box at Twickenham yeah they've got like
你知道他会喜欢什么吗？他会喜欢橄榄球。他会喜欢去看橄榄球赛。在默里菲尔德为英格兰队加油。他会沉浸其中。他是个硬汉，他爸爸在特威克纳姆有包厢，是的，他们有……
barber jackets coming out their ears like hampers and then they're off like he's then he's going to Paul's Ethel Rock with Tabby yeah the weekend absolutely yeah all that yeah yeah
理发师夹克多得数不清，像篮子一样，然后他们就出发了，就像他要去保罗·埃塞尔·洛克和塔比在一起，是的，周末绝对是这样，所有这些，是的，是的。
I mean he would absolutely be going to Murrayfield to cheer on the boys so he's a he's a brilliant fighter against the Scots, and it's actually the Scots who are the first to call him Hotspur. He's become a Knight of the Garter by the age of 24. He's made a brilliant marriage to Elizabeth Mortimer, who is the sister of Roger and Edmund Mortimer,
我的意思是，他绝对会去默里菲尔德为小伙子们加油，所以他是一个对抗苏格兰人的杰出战士，实际上正是苏格兰人最先称他为“霍茨珀”（意为“热刺”）。他在24岁时就成为了嘉德骑士。他与伊丽莎白·莫蒂默结成了美满的婚姻，她是罗杰和埃德蒙·莫蒂默的姐妹，
and therefore aunt to the young Edmund Mortimer, who is the guy who's been appointed by Richard II. Just to make our listeners feel a little bit better about themselves. I'm also confused about the Mortimers, so don't worry. And in Shakespeare, Hotspur's relationship to his wife is brilliantly done. It's incredibly funny. Yeah, but quite moving. They have a very close relationship, don't they?
因此也是年轻的埃德蒙·莫蒂默的姑姑，也就是那个被理查二世任命的人。为了让我们的听众对自己感觉好一点，我也对莫蒂默家族感到困惑，所以别担心。在莎士比亚的剧作中，霍茨珀与妻子的关系处理得非常出色。非常有趣。是的，但也很感人。他们的关系非常亲密，不是吗？
Yeah, because Hotspur never says he loves his wife, but you can see that he completely does. It's really, really wonderfully done. But essentially, his wife is the aunt to the alternative heir to the throne, this young boy, Edmund Mortimer. So that's basically what you need to keep in mind. And basically, he's the greatest warrior in England. He's a tremendous lad.
是的，因为霍茨珀从不说他爱他的妻子，但你能看出他完全爱她。这真的处理得非常非常棒。但本质上，他的妻子是王位另一位继承人——那个小男孩埃德蒙·莫蒂默的姑姑。所以这基本上就是你需要记住的。而且基本上，他是英格兰最伟大的战士。他是个了不起的汉子。
And so Henry IV, I think, admires him. You know, they're companions in arms. And so he gives Hotspur responsibility for the two most potentially unstable parts of his kingdom, one of which is clearly the northern frontier, always unstable. Scots are a constant source of trouble for the English king. But also the Welsh marshes. So this is the north part of Wales, the last bit to be conquered, the hardest for physical reasons, because it's so mountainous. It's the hardest to kind of
所以我认为亨利四世很钦佩他。你知道，他们是并肩作战的伙伴。所以他把王国中两个最可能不稳定的部分交给了霍茨珀负责，其中一个显然是北部边境，一直很不稳定。苏格兰人是英格兰国王不断的麻烦来源。还有威尔士边境。这是威尔士的北部，由于地形原因，这是最后被征服、最难征服的地方，因为那里山峦重叠。这是最难……
stop rebellion happening. And also because it's near to Cheshire, which is the most pro-Richard part of the country. Right, where Richard II had built up his own affinity, just like a magnate. Yeah. So everyone in Cheshire loves Richard II, very resentful that he's been toppled. And also Cheshire is the place more than anywhere else in England that is famed for its longbowmen. Its archery is peerless. So these are potential flashpoints. Hotspur is not the only member of his family to be given signal honors. Northumberland, his father, who had the head of the family, he's been made the constable of England and he's been given responsibility for young Edmund Mortimer's inheritance. So he, in a way, is kind of Edmund Mortimer's guardian.
阻止叛乱发生的地方。而且因为它靠近柴郡，那是全国最支持理查二世的地区。没错，理查二世在那里建立了自己的势力范围，就像个大权贵一样。是的。所以柴郡的每个人都爱理查二世，对他被推翻感到非常愤恨。而且柴郡也是英格兰最以长弓手闻名的地方。那里的箭术是无与伦比的。所以这些都是潜在的爆发点。霍茨珀并不是他家族中唯一获得显赫荣誉的人。他的父亲诺森伯兰伯爵，作为家族首领，被任命为英格兰警卫官，并被赋予了负责年轻埃德蒙·莫蒂默遗产的责任。所以他在某种程度上是埃德蒙·莫蒂默的监护人。
And then there's Northumberland's brother, the Earl of Worcester, who I played in a production of Henry IV, part one, who's a sinister Machiavelle. Right. And he is made Admiral of England. And both men, like Hotspur, are Knights of the Garter. So Henry IV is really kind of lavishing honors on them. And these aren't just marks of gratitude for the fact that the Percys had rallied to his cause when he came back to claim his inheritance. It's also the fact that he really, really needs
还有诺森伯兰的兄弟，伍斯特伯爵，我曾在《亨利四世》第一部的制作中扮演过他，他是一个阴险的马基雅维利主义者。没错。他被任命为英格兰海军上将。而且两人和霍茨珀一样，都是嘉德骑士。所以亨利四世确实在向他们大肆封赏。这些不仅仅是因为珀西家族在他回来索要遗产时支持他而表示的感激，也是因为他真的非常非常需要
to keep them on board, because they're by far the most powerful magnates in the kingdom yeah i mean you lose them you're in real trouble right they control the north so right so that's them what about um prince how is prince how dressing up and attacking people on country by ways is he getting drunk with madams? Roistering with full staff? Yeah. Is he doing all that? Is that any truth in that at all?
留住他们，因为他们是王国里最强大的权贵，没有之一。是的，我的意思是，失去他们你就真的有大麻烦了。没错，他们控制着北方。所以，这就是他们。那么，哈尔王子呢？哈尔王子是在乡间小路上装扮自己并袭击路人吗？他是在和老鸨们喝酒吗？和福斯塔夫一起狂欢吗？是的。他在做所有这些事吗？这其中有任何真实成分吗？
Well, he's only 13 when his father is crowned. Yeah. So he's very young. He does do a kind of Penny Mordant and carry a sword at his father's coronation. Poor Penny Mordant. Where's she now? Yeah, where's she gone? So he does that.
嗯，他父亲加冕时他才13岁。是的。所以他非常年轻。他确实在父亲的加冕典礼上像佩妮·莫当特那样拿着剑。可怜的佩妮·莫当特。她现在在哪儿？是的，她去哪儿了？所以他做了那个。
And then two days after Henry's coron gone so he does that and then two days after henry's coronation he is made prince of wales he's made duke of cornwall all of which is you know traditionally the the elder son of the the king and he's made earl of chester right and that also is a traditional title but of course you know as we said chester is the county town of cheshire this is the most sensitive part in England, the most hostile to Henry. But Henry IV wants his son in at the deep end. He doesn't want him to be a kind of Richard. He wants him going into the school of hard knocks, learning his craft as a future king. So in the summer of 1400, the young prince, who by now is 14, accompanies his father on
然后在亨利加冕两天后，他被封为威尔士亲王，被封为康沃尔公爵，所有这些都是国王长子的传统头衔，他还被封为切斯特伯爵，没错，这也是一个传统头衔，但当然，正如我们所说，切斯特是柴郡的郡治，这是英格兰最敏感的部分，也是对亨利最敌视的部分。但亨利四世想让他的儿子深入一线。他不希望他成为像理查那样的人。他希望他进入“硬汉学校”，学习作为未来国王的本领。所以1400年夏天，当时14岁的年轻王子陪同他的父亲进行了一次
an abortive invasion of Scotland. And then in that autumn of 1400, he's sent off to Chester as the Earl of Chester, basically to see what it's like to be in a very rebellious area of the country. But that surely works both ways, right? So it's good for him, but it's also good for Cheshire, because if Cheshire is rid of the Second's heartland, you want to make them feel special. Exactly. So by sending your son, you're basically saying,
对苏格兰的流产入侵。然后在1400年秋天，他被派往切斯特担任切斯特伯爵，基本上是为了看看在一个非常叛逆的地区是什么感觉。但这肯定对双方都有利，对吧？所以这对他有好处，但对柴郡也有好处，因为如果柴郡是理查二世的大本营，你想让他们感到特别。没错。所以通过派你的儿子去，你基本上是在说，
you're still a little bit special because I'm sending my son to govern you, and I'm respecting your difference, as it were. I think that's absolutely right. But in the event, it's not actually Cheshire that is the cause of trouble but wales and wales is right next to cheshire and wales in the autumn of 1400 erupts into rebellion in a way that i mean is really startling because as we said wales has been conquered for a century um subdued by edward i who built a chain of great castles across the northern reaches of the principality, had named his son, the future Edward II, Prince of Wales.
你们仍然有点特别，因为我派我的儿子来治理你们，我尊重你们的差异。我认为这绝对正确。但事实上，造成麻烦的并不是柴郡，而是威尔士，威尔士就在柴郡旁边。1400年秋天，威尔士爆发了叛乱，这种方式真的令人震惊，因为正如我们所说，威尔士已经被征服了一个世纪，被爱德华一世征服，他在公国北部边缘建造了一连串伟大的城堡，并命名他的儿子，未来的爱德华二世为威尔士亲王。
And that's a title that Prince Henry has now succeeded Prince Hal. But on the 16th of September 1400, even before the prince has arrived in Cheshire, another man, a Welshman, has laid claim to the title of Prince of Wales. And this is a man called Owen Glyndwr. And he is a man who has the blood of Welsh princes in his veins. So Rhys Davies, who's the great historian of late medieval Wales and has written a brilliant book on Glendower's rebellion. He writes, nobody needed to flatter or lie in the recital of Owen's genealogy. It was the finest in Wales.
那是亨利王子现在继承的头衔，哈尔王子。但在1400年9月16日，甚至在王子到达柴郡之前，另一个人，一个威尔士人，已经宣称拥有威尔士亲王的头衔。这个人叫欧文·格林道尔。他是一个血管里流淌着威尔士亲王血统的人。所以里斯·戴维斯，这位中世纪晚期威尔士的伟大历史学家，写了一本关于格林道尔叛乱的精彩著作。他写道，在讲述欧文的家谱时，没有人需要奉承或撒谎。那是威尔士最好的血统。
The finest blood in Wales, Tom. Amazing. He has the blood of the two great princely lines in his veins. So, you know, great subject for Bardic song. Yeah. And I think it's fair to say that Owen Glendower is a great man for a Bardic song.
威尔士最好的血统，汤姆。太棒了。他的血管里流淌着两个伟大亲王家族的血。所以，你知道，这是吟游诗人歌曲的绝佳题材。是的，我认为可以公平地说，欧文·格林道尔是吟游诗人歌曲的伟大素材。
Well, the trouble is that the English, and some people would say this is a theme of Anglo-Welsh history, the English don't treat him with the seriousness that he thinks he deserves. That's right, isn't it? No, because as I say,
嗯，问题在于英国人——有些人会说这是英威尔历史的一个主题——英国人并没有以他认为他应得的严肃态度对待他。没错，是这样，对吧？不，因为正如我所说，
Wales has been conquered for a century. He's, I mean, he may have the blood of princes in his veins, but he's still only a kind of member of the minor gentry. It's absolutely ridiculous that this upstart should think to challenge the authentic Prince of Wales and the might of the English king. So they do see it as kind of basically a bit ridiculous. And I think that reflects the fact that Wales at this point is kind of halfway house. I mean, it is still Welsh, but it has been anglicized pretty strongly. And you can see this in the figure of Owen himself. So in lots of ways, he's quite assimilated.
威尔士已经被征服了一个世纪。他，我的意思是，他血管里可能有亲王的血，但他仍然只是一个小地主。这个暴发户竟然想挑战真正的威尔士亲王和英格兰国王的威力，这简直太荒谬了。所以他们确实认为这基本上有点荒谬。我认为这反映了一个事实，即此时的威尔士处于一种中间状态。我的意思是，它仍然是威尔士的，但它已经被相当强烈地英格兰化了。你可以从欧文本人身上看到这一点。所以在很多方面，他相当同化。
He's trained as a lawyer in London. He served in the garrison at Berwick-upon-Tweed. His wife is of English descent, but he is also full of seething resentments, which are entirely legitimate because Wales is subject to laws that were instituted by Edward I that have basically imposed a form of apartheid on the principality. The Welsh are legally penalized in all kinds of ways. They're stopped from wielding power. Their economic opportunities are very much inhibited by the economic rights that are given to English settlers. And I think that, you know, these have always been resented
他在伦敦接受过律师培训。他在特威德河畔贝里克驻军服役。他的妻子是英格兰血统，但他内心也充满了沸腾的怨恨，这些怨恨是完全合法的，因为威尔士受到爱德华一世制定的法律的约束，这些法律基本上在公国实行了一种种族隔离。威尔士人在各方面都受到法律惩罚。他们被禁止行使权力。他们的经济机会受到给予英格兰定居者的经济权利的极大抑制。我认为，你知道，这些一直被威尔士贵族所怨恨。
by the Welsh aristocracy. And you might say, Dominic, that the kindling is in place and that Owen's claim to be the Prince of Wales is the striking of the match. But it's not the spark that he has a row with his neighbour. Correct. Lord Ruthyn Reginald Grey. Yes. It's always the way that it's your neighbours, the people you really have to fear. Yes.
多米尼克，你可能会说，引火物已经就位，欧文宣称自己是威尔士亲王就是划火柴的动作。但这并不是他与邻居发生争吵的导火索。没错。鲁辛勋爵雷金纳德·格雷。是的。总是这样，你真正需要害怕的是你的邻居。是的。
So they've basically been, they hate each other. They've been kind of quarrelling over, you know, ditches. Arcing about a fence. Yeah. Cows wandering into each other's lands and all that kind of thing. And basically, Owen has this blazing row with Lord Ruthyn. And it's this that prompts him to go storming off
所以他们基本上，他们互相憎恨。他们一直在为，你知道，沟渠争吵。为了篱笆争吵。是的。牛闯进对方的土地等等。基本上，欧文和鲁辛勋爵发生了激烈的争吵。正是这件事促使他冲了出去，
and saying that he's the Prince of Wales, which is obviously a brilliant way of upstaging his near neighbor. But there is no question that in doing that, this argument over who's building the fence on the lower field, it explodes because there is this incredible Welsh sense of nationalist resentment. And the moment he's made this announcement, it's not just his own feudal followers, but people from across Northern Wales who kind of flock to his banner. And they just go on the rampage. They kind of go sweeping off. They burn all Ruthens Fields. They go off and they attack all kinds of English settlements across Northern Wales. And Rhys Davies says
并声称他是威尔士亲王，这显然是压倒他近邻的一种绝妙方式。但毫无疑问，在这样做的时候，这场关于谁在下层田地建篱笆的争论爆发了，因为有一种令人难以置信的威尔士民族主义怨恨感。他一宣布这个消息，不仅是他的封建追随者，而且来自威尔士北部各地的人们都涌向他的旗帜。他们就开始横冲直撞。他们横扫一切。他们烧毁了鲁辛所有的田地。他们跑去攻击威尔士北部各地的各种英格兰定居点。里斯·戴维斯说
from the beginning, Owen's crusade was anti-English, that this is a kind of proto-nationalist rebellion. And Henry, when he's informed of this, I mean, he takes it seriously, but not too seriously, because despite the fact that a lot of fields are being burned, Owen Glyndaur and his followers are in no position to kind of capture castles, to actually seize towns permanently. And seven days after he's proclaimed himself Prince of Wales, he's defeated in a skirmish. So it looks like actually, you know, it's blazed up and it's going to die down again. But then what happens is that in Anglesey, so the island off the northwest of Wales, another uprising is launched. And this is launched by two brothers,
从一开始，欧文的十字军东征就是反英的，这是一种原始民族主义叛乱。亨利在得知此事后，我的意思是，他认真对待，但没有太认真，因为尽管很多田地被烧毁，欧文·格林道尔和他的追随者根本无法占领城堡，无法真正永久地夺取城镇。在他宣布自己为威尔士亲王七天后，他在一场小规模冲突中被击败。所以看起来，你知道，它爆发了，然后又会平息下去。但随后发生的事情是，在安格尔西岛，也就是威尔士西北部的岛屿上，又爆发了另一次起义。这是由两兄弟发起的，
Rhys and Gwilym Apatuda. It's a name to conjure with. Yeah, a name to conjure with. So therefore you have these two kind of uprisings in Wales and they must surely have been coordinated. Right. I was going to ask about that. Yeah. Do we know whether they are writing to each other or sending messages, the Tudors and Glendower? We don't for sure, but I think so. Okay. I think the consensus would be that yes, this is a coordinated uprising. So in October of 1400, Henry marches into the north. He goes all the way to Caernarfon on the coast of Wales, the northwest coast of Wales. He boosts up the garrison of all these kind of castles that had been built by Edward I, the fetters that had been
里斯和格威利姆·阿帕图达。这是一个值得一提的名字。是的，一个值得一提的名字。所以你有这两场威尔士的起义，它们肯定是被协调过的。没错。我正要问那个。是的。我们知道他们是否在互相写信或发送信息吗，都铎家族和格林道尔？我们不确定，但我认为是这样。好吧。我认为共识是，是的，这是一场协调一致的起义。所以1400年10月，亨利向北进军。他一直走到威尔士海岸的卡那封，威尔士西北海岸。他加强了所有这些由爱德华一世建造的城堡的驻军，那些被投在威尔士人身上的枷锁，
thrown over the Welsh. He executes various rebels that he's taken prisoner and the rebellion seems over. But it isn't because on the 1st of April, April Fool's Day of the following year, which is also Good Friday, the captain of Conway Castle, one of these great Edwardian castles, It's Good Friday. He goes off to a church service. He takes all but five of the garrison with him. So essentially there's only a kind of skeleton staff. And while he's at church, Gwilym Tudor, who's still very much on the scene, he's got 40 men with him. They sneak their way into the castle and they seize control of it. And this is an amazing stunt.
他处决了各种被俘的叛军，叛乱似乎结束了。但事实并非如此，因为在第二年的4月1日，愚人节，也就是耶稣受难日，康威城堡的指挥官，这些伟大的爱德华时代城堡之一，那是耶稣受难日。他去参加教堂礼拜。他带走了除五名驻军以外的所有人。所以基本上只有一个骨干人员。当他在教堂时，格威利姆·都铎，他仍然在现场，他带着40个人。他们溜进城堡并夺取了控制权。这是一个惊人的特技。
It seems to have come from nowhere. And they managed to hold out for two months, even though both Hotspur and the prince, so Prince Hal and Hotspur working together, they lay siege to it. And it's only at the end of May that William Tudor negotiates a surrender. And the terms are that they have to hand over nine of their defenders, who are predictably put to death very horribly, but the rest of them march out. And it's just a tremendous
它似乎是凭空出现的。他们设法坚持了两个月，尽管霍茨珀和王子，也就是哈尔王子和霍茨珀一起合作，对它进行了围攻。直到5月底，威廉·都铎才谈判投降。条件是他们必须交出九名守军，他们不出所料地被非常可怕地处决了，但其余的人走了出来。这简直是一个巨大的
propaganda coup and it's talked of across Wales. And so the impact of this on the Welsh is to make them think, brilliant, you know, we could have a crack at the English. This is the kind of the boldness, the daring that might actually enable us to throw off the English yoke. And in England, it causes outrage. And so in London, the parliament says, you know, we've got to come down hard on this. And members of parliament in London, they force through all these very, very kind of retributive laws, the penal laws they're called, which are explicitly anti-Welsh statutes and ordinances. And Rhys Davies says, you know, they are utterly racist and also completely
宣传政变，整个威尔士都在谈论它。因此，这对威尔士人的影响是让他们认为，太棒了，你知道，我们可以试着对付英国人。这就是那种可能真正使我们摆脱英国枷锁的胆识和勇气。而在英格兰，它引起了愤怒。所以伦敦的议会说，你知道，我们必须严厉打击这一点。伦敦的议会议员们强行通过了所有这些非常非常具有报复性的法律，即所谓的刑法，这些法律是明确的反威尔士法规和条例。里斯·戴维斯说，你知道，它们是彻头彻尾的种族主义，而且完全
counterproductive because that sense of a kind of certain commonality between the Welsh and the English, a sense that the Welsh are becoming English, that the English are becoming Welsh, it tears it up. The two sides become completely polarised again. So here's your classic example of a kind of proto-colonialist administration, not winning hearts and minds. And such administrations win when they persuade the bulk of kind of non-aligned opinion to support them. But what the English have done here is driven them away. Yeah. And I think that, you know, to a degree, the English had succeeded
适得其反，因为那种威尔士人和英国人之间的某种共同感，一种威尔士人正在变成英国人，英国人正在变成威尔士人的感觉，被撕碎了。双方再次完全两极分化。所以这是某种原始殖民主义行政管理的一个典型例子，没有赢得人心。而这样的行政管理在说服大多数非结盟意见支持他们时才会获胜。但英国人在这里所做的是把他们赶走了。是的。我认为，在某种程度上，英国人已经成功了
in persuading the Welsh to, you know, assimilate. And Owen Glendower being a kind of example of that. But this just totally explodes that. And the rebellion escalates and escalates and escalates. And it spreads from North Wales, which had always been the hotbed of Welsh resistance, down into the central Wales. And even there are kind of bushfires of rebellion in southern Wales. So Henry IV launches another invasion, but the Welsh just kind of melt into
说服威尔士人，你知道，同化。欧文·格林道尔就是一个例子。但这完全引爆了这一点。叛乱升级、升级、再升级。它从一直是威尔士抵抗温床的北威尔士蔓延到威尔士中部。甚至在威尔士南部也有某种叛乱的野火。所以亨利四世发动了另一次入侵，但威尔士人只是融化在
the hills. And the moment Henry IV is withdrawn, Glyndwr pops out again from his mountain fastnesses. And this time he's got an absolutely brilliant banner and it's a golden dragon on a white field. So not a red dragon. No, apparently it's a golden dragon, but there are lots of red dragons. I mean, basically there are dragons everywhere. Yeah. And it's all tremendous excitement.
山丘中。亨利四世一撤退，格林道尔又从他的山中堡垒中冒了出来。这一次他有一面绝对精彩的旗帜，是一条白底金龙。所以不是红龙。不，显然是一条金龙，但有很多红龙。我的意思是，基本上到处都是龙。是的。这真是令人兴奋。
And there are prophecies and more prophecies from Merlin and it's all kicking off. And the following year, there are two brilliant victories for Owen, for Glyndaur. So in the first of them, he captures his old enemy, Reginald Grey, Lord Ruffin. And Grey is kind of led away on a donkey, bound tightly with thongs, the chronicler says. He's now bitterly regretting that boundary dispute that kicked the whole thing off. Yeah, he really is.
还有来自梅林的预言和更多的预言，一切都开始了。第二年，欧文，格林道尔，取得了两次辉煌的胜利。在第一次胜利中，他俘虏了他的老敌人，雷金纳德·格雷，鲁辛勋爵。编年史家说，格雷被紧紧地绑在驴子上带走了。他现在非常后悔那场引发这一切的边界纠纷。是的，他确实是。
He should have just let them have the dit. And then shortly after that, there's an even more extraordinary victory for the Welsh. And this happens at a place called Pyllith, which is just inside Wales. And I visited it actually a few weeks ago. I did a road trip from Rye to Aberystwyth and we stopped at this place and it's a church on a hill and the Welsh had occupied it. And the guy who comes to attack them is Edmund Mortimer, who is the uncle of the younger Edmund, so confusing, the younger Edmund Mortimer, who's the heir to the throne, who's stuck in Windsor. Yeah. It's his uncle. Okay. Another Edmund Mortimer. Yeah. It's his uncle. And he goes and attacks the Welsh. And it's a very steep hill.
他本应该让他们拥有那条沟渠。然后不久之后，威尔士人取得了更非凡的胜利。这发生在威尔士境内一个叫皮利斯的地方。我几周前实际上参观过它。我从莱伊开车去阿伯里斯特威斯，我们在那个地方停了下来，那是一座山上的教堂，威尔士人占领了它。去攻击他们的人是埃德蒙·莫蒂默，他是年轻埃德蒙的叔叔，太令人困惑了，年轻的埃德蒙·莫蒂默，他是王位继承人，被困在温莎。是的。是他的叔叔。好吧。另一个埃德蒙·莫蒂默。是的。是他的叔叔。他去攻击威尔士人。那是一座非常陡峭的山。
And it's a mad thing to do when you see it. And he charges up a hill and his men get wiped out and he gets captured. And English dead are left scattered all over the hillside. And this features in the very opening of Henry IV, part one, where the description of the English dead, it's beastly, shameless transformation. And what Shakespeare means by that is that they're all genitally mutilated. The Welsh women, it is said, go out and just kind of hack off the genitals of the dead and dying English. Now it has to be said that Rhys Davies says that this is just English propaganda. A number of
当你看到它时，这是一件疯狂的事情。他冲上一座山，他的人被消灭了，他被俘虏了。英格兰人的尸体散落在山坡上。这在《亨利四世》第一部的开篇中就有体现，对英格兰死者的描述，那是卑鄙的、无耻的转变。莎士比亚的意思是他们都被生殖器残害了。据说威尔士妇女出去把死去的和垂死的英国人的生殖器割掉了。现在必须说，里斯·戴维斯说这只是英国的宣传。一些
English historians that I've read all say, yes, this happened. So kind of interesting perspective, difference of perspective there. It wouldn't be unusual for it to happen, would it? I mean, I think back to the series we did about the American West. There was an awful lot of that kind of carry on there. I think the reason why Rhys-Davies would say
我读过的英国历史学家都说，是的，这发生了。所以视角有点有趣，视角的差异。这发生并不罕见，不是吗？我的意思是，我回想起我们制作的关于美国西部的系列节目。那里有很多那种行为。我认为里斯·戴维斯会说
it was English propaganda is... Is he Welsh? Well, no, it's the fact that this is not the kind of behaviour that is expected of the defeated on a Christian battlefield. And it's casting the Welsh as sinister, pagan, barbarous savages. So I'm not qualified to say whether it happened or not. But certainly the English thought it. I think this happens all the time in history.
这是英国的宣传是因为……他是威尔士人吗？嗯，不，事实是，这不是在基督教战场上战败者所期望的行为。它把威尔士人描绘成阴险的、异教的、野蛮的野蛮人。所以我没有资格说它是否发生过。但英国人肯定这么认为。我认为这在历史上一直发生。
Yeah, well, maybe. Yeah, I don't think it's unusually Welsh. I just think it's standard conduct, actually. I don't think it is. I don't think that after a battle, people, women come out and hack off testicles in medieval Europe, by and large. Dominic pulling a face.
是的，好吧，也许吧。是的，我不认为这是威尔士特有的。我只是认为这实际上是标准行为。我不认为在中世纪欧洲，战斗结束后，人们，妇女出来割掉睾丸。多米尼克做了一个鬼脸。
I think, well, I think if they didn't... Because it causes a scandal. If they didn't, I feel like they should have done. Anyway, let's continue. Okay, all right. So it's lots of bad blood in England't, I feel like they should have done. Anyway, let's continue. Okay. All right. So it's lots of bad blood in England because people are telling the story and believing it. And so Henry leads another expedition. And this one is even worse because it's an incredibly violent storm.
我想，嗯，我想如果他们没有……因为它引起了丑闻。如果他们没有，我觉得他们应该这样做。无论如何，让我们继续。好的，好的。所以英格兰有很多积怨，因为人们在讲述这个故事并相信它。所以亨利领导了另一次远征。而这一次更糟，因为这是一场极其猛烈的风暴。
And it flattens the king's tent. There's great lightning bolt incinerates it. And Henry could very easily have died. And of course, everyone in Wales says that this has been conjured up by Glendower's magicians. So there's a general sense. This is great. You know, we're hacking off testicles. We've got storms.
它夷平了国王的帐篷。巨大的闪电把它烧毁了。亨利很容易就会死掉。当然，威尔士的每个人都说这是格林道尔的魔术师变出来的。所以有一种普遍的感觉。这太棒了。你知道，我们割掉了睾丸。我们有风暴。
We've got dragons. It's absolutely brilliant. Just on the magicians. So magicians didn't play any part. You did a series about the Hundred Years' War with the Third. I don't recall any magicians in that series. No. Do the English genuinely believe that the Welsh have magicians on their side, kind of druid figures
我们有龙。这绝对太棒了。关于魔术师。所以魔术师没有发挥任何作用。你制作了一个关于第三次百年战争的系列节目。我不记得那个系列里有任何魔术师。不。英国人真的相信威尔士人有魔术师在他们那边吗，某种德鲁伊人物
or something? Because in Shakespeare's play, O'England Tower is a kind of comedy magician, isn't he? Not exactly a comedy. Well, maybe that's just the productions I've seen generally play it for laughs. Hotspur laughs at him. Yeah.
之类的？因为在莎士比亚的戏剧中，欧文·格林道尔是一个喜剧魔术师，不是吗？不完全是喜剧。嗯，也许那只是我看到的通常为了笑声而表演的制作。霍茨珀嘲笑他。是的。
But there's a sense that he's a very, actually, I mean, I think Shakespeare presents him as being very formidable. He's called the great magician. Yeah, I think there is. And I think that the English play it up as a way of showing how the Welsh are just, you know, they're just savages. And the Welsh play it up because it's a way of intimidating the English. And also it's true to traditions that the English don't have. So I think it's, you know, for all these reasons, the idea that, uh, Glendower has access to supernatural powers that, you know, the, the, the lumpen English in their plodding armor don't have is an important part of his image. And, you know, Henry is for the moment powerless to do anything about it yeah his style
但有一种感觉，他非常，实际上，我的意思是，我认为莎士比亚把他表现得非常强大。他被称为伟大的魔术师。是的，我想有。我认为英国人把它当作一种展示威尔士人只是，你知道，他们只是野蛮人的方式。而威尔士人把它当作一种恐吓英国人的方式。而且它也符合英国人没有的传统。所以我认为，你知道，由于所有这些原因，格林道尔可以获得超自然力量的想法，你知道，那些穿着笨重盔甲的笨拙的英国人没有，这是他形象的重要组成部分。而且，你知道，亨利目前无能为力，无法对此做任何事情。是的，他的风格
of fighting is inadequate to cope with the kind of guerrilla warfare that that england dower is is is the master of but now he's facing trouble on another front isn't he because it's not just the the western border but up north yeah in your neck of the woods, Tom, near your country estate. There's all kinds of ructions going on. Yeah. So, of course, because the Scots, they're kept informed of what's going on in Wales and they think this is a perfect opportunity to launch a great raid on the north.
战斗方式不足以应付格林道尔所掌握的游击战。但现在他在另一个战线上也面临麻烦，不是吗？因为不仅仅是西部边界，还有北方。是的，在你的家乡附近，汤姆，在你的乡村庄园附近。发生了各种各样的骚乱。是的。所以，当然，因为苏格兰人，他们随时了解威尔士发生的事情，他们认为这是一个对北方发动大突袭的绝佳机会。
So this happens in September 1402 and it's led by the most formidable military figure in Scotland, who's a guy called the Earl of Douglas. And he leads his men across the Tweed and heads southwards down towards Newcastle, plundering and looting as he goes. And Hotspur, who's in Wales, is sent news. He goes galloping up using his hotspurs to join his father and the two men meet up. And although they are ready to oppose the Scots, it's clear that they are full of festering resentments against Henry. So hotspur is going not just to oppose Douglas, but to have a council of war with his father. So hotspur disagrees with Henry IV's strategy of fighting Oenglindar. He thinks
所以这发生在1402年9月，由苏格兰最强大的军事人物领导，一个叫道格拉斯伯爵的人。他带领他的人越过特威德河，向南朝纽卡斯尔进发，一路掠夺。而在威尔士的霍茨珀得到了消息。他飞奔而去，用他的热刺加入他的父亲，两人会合。虽然他们准备反对苏格兰人，但很明显他们对亨利充满了积怨。所以霍茨珀去不仅是为了反对道格拉斯，还要和他的父亲召开军事会议。所以霍茨珀不同意亨利四世对抗欧文·格林道尔的战略。他认为
that there should be negotiations, that an accommodation should be arrived at. He feels that the Prince of Wales is stepping on his toes as Prince Hal gets older. So he's starting to muscle in on a sphere of activity that Hotspur feels is his own. And most incendiary of all, there is the fact that Edmund Mortimer, who is Hotspur's brother-in-law now because Hotspur is married to Edmund Mortimer's sister, he's not being ransomed. Henry IV is refusing to ransom him and is refusing Edmund Mortimer the right to ransom himself. And the reason for this very obviously is that the Mortimers are potential rivals. So Henry actually having him captive in Welsh hands is really good, but Hotspur is very, very resentful of this. And so he and his father consult. But before they can
应该进行谈判，应该达成妥协。他觉得随着哈尔王子的长大，威尔士亲王正在踩他的脚趾。所以他开始挤进霍茨珀认为是属于他自己的活动领域。最煽动性的是，埃德蒙·莫蒂默，他现在是霍茨珀的姐夫，因为霍茨珀娶了埃德蒙·莫蒂默的姐妹，他没有被赎回。亨利四世拒绝赎回他，并拒绝埃德蒙·莫蒂默赎回自己的权利。而这非常明显的原因是莫蒂默家族是潜在的竞争对手。所以亨利实际上让他被威尔士人俘虏真的很好，但霍茨珀对此非常非常怨恨。所以他和他的父亲商量。但在他们能
decide what to do about Henry IV, the immediate challenge, of course, is to oppose this great Scottish invasion. So what Hotspur does is he raises the forces of the Percys, and he's told that the Earl of Douglas has sacked Newcastle, stripped it bare, and is heading back north up the Great Road towards the Tweed and Scotland. And what Hotspur does is to draw up his men in the shadow of this great Iron Age hill fort called Humbleton Hill, blocking the road north to the Tweed. And again, Dominic, I've had an absolute time of it recently with early 15th century battlefields, because I went and visited this as well just a few days ago. It's very, very dramatic. You've been walking the ground. I have been walking the ground like my brother does
决定对亨利四世做什么之前，直接的挑战当然是反对这次伟大的苏格兰入侵。所以霍茨珀所做的是他召集了珀西家族的军队，他被告知道格拉斯伯爵已经洗劫了纽卡斯尔，把它剥得精光，并正沿着通往特威德和苏格兰的大路向北返回。霍茨珀所做的是在他被称为亨布尔顿山的铁器时代山堡的阴影下集结他的人，封锁了通往特威德的北路。同样，多米尼克，我最近在15世纪初的战场上度过了一段绝对的时光，因为我几天前也去参观了这个地方。它非常非常戏剧性。你一直在走那片土地。我一直在走那片土地，就像我兄弟那样
when he goes off to Dunkirk or Arnhem or whatever. So I went off to Humbleton Hill. And when Douglas sees the English lined up in front of him, he withdraws up into the foothills of this Iron Age hill fort and kind of sits there and waits for the English to disperse. But the problem for him is that Percy has an enormous number of longbowmen. And so the longbowmen just line up and fire volley after volley after volley at the Scots up on their hill and completely wipes them out. So a chronicler
当他去敦刻尔克或阿纳姆或什么地方时。所以我去了亨布尔顿山。当道格拉斯看到英国人在他面前排成一行时，他撤退到这个铁器时代山堡的山脚下，坐在那里等待英国人散去。但他面临的问题是珀西有大量的长弓手。所以长弓手们只是排成一行，向山上的苏格兰人发射了一轮又一轮的箭，完全消灭了他们。所以一位编年史家
describes the Scots as looking like a hedgehog. They've got so many kind of arrows sticking out of them. And essentially the entire army is wiped out. There's a desperate charge at the end, led by Douglas, but it doesn't work. Douglas gets hit in the eye, loses an eye. A thousand prisoners are taken, including Douglas. And again, a chronicler celebrates this and says, the flower of the fighting men of the whole realm of Scotland. So it's a brilliant, brilliant victory. And for Henry IV, of course, this is a rare bit of good news. He's had all
描述苏格兰人看起来像一只刺猬。他们身上插着太多的箭。基本上整支军队都被消灭了。最后有一次由道格拉斯领导的绝望冲锋，但没有奏效。道格拉斯眼睛中箭，失去了一只眼睛。一千名俘虏被带走，包括道格拉斯。同样，一位编年史家庆祝这一点并说，苏格兰整个王国的战斗人员之花。所以这是一个辉煌的、辉煌的胜利。对于亨利四世来说，当然，这是一个罕见的好消息。他经历了所有
these kind of troubles all over his kingdom. So this great victory of the Scots, fabulous. Or is it? Because even here, it kind of goes wrong because the fact that all these prisoners have been taken on one level is wonderful because it's a source of income. They can now be ransomed off and this money can then be used to fight the Welsh. Yeah, because it's expensive to fight wars. So fighting the Welsh is really expensive. And also there's been a visit to England by, amazingly, a Roman emperor, the emperor of Constantinople. Manuel II. Brilliant.
这些在他王国各处的麻烦。所以苏格兰的这场大胜利，太棒了。或者说，是吗？因为即使在这里，它也出了问题，因为在某种程度上，所有这些俘虏被带走是美妙的，因为它是收入来源。他们现在可以被赎回，这些钱可以用来对抗威尔士人。是的，因为打仗很贵。所以对抗威尔士人真的很贵。而且，令人惊讶的是，一位罗马皇帝，君士坦丁堡的皇帝，曼努埃尔二世，访问了英格兰。太棒了。
So the first visit to Britain by a Roman emperor since the 4th century. That's amazing. That is amazing. Yeah. Henry IV had an amazing life. Went off to the Baltic,
所以这是自4世纪以来罗马皇帝对英国的首次访问。太神奇了。这太神奇了。是的。亨利四世有着惊人的一生。去了波罗的海，
went to Jerusalem, welcomed a Roman emperor. Had an ostrich. Yeah. Interfered with the Welsh. I mean, an incredible career. Anyway, continue. Yeah, so that had been very expensive
去了耶路撒冷，欢迎了一位罗马皇帝。有一只鸵鸟。是的。干涉了威尔士人。我的意思是，一个不可思议的职业生涯。无论如何，继续。是的，所以那非常昂贵
and now he's got this rebellion in Wales. So basically, he's got massive financial drain. Parliament is resentful. Remember, he'd come to power saying he wouldn't, you know, he wouldn't be screwing money out of them. And now all he does is ask them for money. Mobs in London are starting to get resentful. They're turning against the King and inevitably rumors are starting to spread that Richard II is alive. So there's this kitchen boy called Thomas Ward, who's appeared in Scotland claiming to be Richard II. So Henry IV is facing a host of problems and at the root of all of them
现在他在威尔士有这场叛乱。所以基本上，他有巨大的财政消耗。议会很怨恨。记住，他上台时说他不会，你知道，他不会从他们那里榨钱。而现在他所做的只是向他们要钱。伦敦的暴民开始变得怨恨。他们开始反对国王，不可避免地开始流传理查二世还活着的谣言。所以有一个叫托马斯·沃德的厨房男孩，他出现在苏格兰，声称自己是理查二世。所以亨利四世面临着一系列问题，而所有这些问题的根源
is a lack of money. So unsurprisingly, when he gets the news from Humbleton Hill, he writes to the Percys and says, you know, you are not allowed to ransom any of your prisoners without discussing it with me. And you have to send your highest ranking prisoners, including obviously Douglas, to Westminster. So Hotspur, very resentful of this. He sends seven prisoners, but he doesn't send Douglas because he's, you know, he's really getting fed up with Henry IV. And he's the kind of guy who, when he gets fed up, he shows it. And even when Hotspur does come down to London, summoned by Henry, he still doesn't bring Douglas.
是缺钱。所以不出所料，当他从亨布尔顿山得到消息时，他写信给珀西家族说，你知道，未经与我讨论，你们不允许赎回任何俘虏。你们必须把你们最高级别的俘虏，显然包括道格拉斯，送到威斯敏斯特。所以霍茨珀对此非常怨恨。他送了七名俘虏，但他没有送道格拉斯，因为他，你知道，他真的受够了亨利四世。而且他是那种，当他受够了时，他会表现出来的人。即使霍茨珀来到伦敦，被亨利传唤，他仍然没有带道格拉斯。
So the King and Hotspur have an absolutely blazing row. And remember, they are old comrades in arms. They're like old teammates, aren't they, who've fallen out? They are old teammates. Yeah. Yeah. So Hotspur blames Henry for refusing to ransom Edmund Mortimer. Henry brushes this accusation aside, but it's clear that he has an additional
所以国王和霍茨珀发生了激烈的争吵。记住，他们是并肩作战的老战友。他们就像老队友，不是吗，闹翻了？他们是老队友。是的。是的。所以霍茨珀指责亨利拒绝赎回埃德蒙·莫蒂默。亨利把这个指控撇在一边，但很明显他有一个额外的
reason now for not ransoming Edmund Mortimer, which is basically that Edmund Mortimer, who's stuck with Owen Glyndaur, has decided to switch sides. And in November 1402, completely shocking news reaches London that Edmund has married Owen Glendower's daughter, Catherine, which in turn means that Hotspur is now related by marriage to Owen Glendower. Yeah, that's a twist. Both of them are married to, you know, Edmund Mortimer has married Owen Glendower's daughter. Hotspur is married to Edmund Mortimer's sister. So, you know, this isn't looking good for Henry IV at all. But despite all this, you know, he doesn't want to think that the Percys are going to
现在不赎回埃德蒙·莫蒂默的原因，基本上是埃德蒙·莫蒂默，他被困在欧文·格林道尔那里，决定倒戈。1402年11月，令人震惊的消息传到伦敦，埃德蒙娶了欧文·格林道尔的女儿凯瑟琳，这反过来意味着霍茨珀现在通过婚姻与欧文·格林道尔有亲戚关系。是的，这是一个转折。他们俩都娶了，你知道，埃德蒙·莫蒂默娶了欧文·格林道尔的女儿。霍茨珀娶了埃德蒙·莫蒂默的姐妹。所以，你知道，这对亨利四世来说一点也不好。但尽管所有这些，你知道，他不想认为珀西家族会
turn against him. He wants to believe that they will stick by him. He can't afford to have them turn against him. So going into 1403, Henry essentially tries to kind of bribe the Percys back into supporting him. So on the 1st of March, the Earl of Northumberland, Hotspur's father, is given the earldom of Douglas. So essentially all the Douglas's lands, a vast swathe of southern Scotland, with the implication that it's now the Percy's responsibility to stop faffing around, you know, dabbling their fingers in potential rebellion,
反对他。他想相信他们会坚持支持他。他负担不起让他们反对他。所以进入1403年，亨利基本上试图用贿赂的方式让珀西家族重新支持他。所以3月1日，诺森伯兰伯爵，霍茨珀的父亲，被授予道格拉斯伯爵领地。所以基本上是道格拉斯所有的土地，苏格兰南部的一大片土地，暗示现在珀西家族的责任是停止胡闹，你知道，在潜在的叛乱中沾手，
but to go off into southern Scotland and conquer it for England and for Henry and for themselves. But to be fair, you could argue that is very smart statesmanship. He's giving the Percys a hell of an incentive to stick with him because he's saying you will increase a hell of an incentive to stick with him because he's saying you will increase your domain by an enormous margin. You'll take a huge chunk of Scotland. I mean, you'll be even more powerful than you are already. I mean, I think that it's a good offer. There's a slight problem in Wales where the prince has now come of age. He's now 16. So he has to be
而是去苏格兰南部为英格兰、为亨利、也为他们自己征服它。但公平地说，你可以说这是非常聪明的政治家风度。他给了珀西家族一个巨大的动力去坚持支持他，因为他说你们将增加一个巨大的动力去坚持支持他，因为他说你们将增加你们的领地，幅度非常大。你们将占领苏格兰的一大块。我的意思是，你们将比现在更强大。我的意思是，我认为这是一个很好的提议。威尔士有一个小问题，王子现在已经成年了。他现在16岁了。所以他必须是
given command of the Welsh war. But again, Henry IV is careful not to tread on Percy toes. And so he makes the Earl of Worcester, the Admiral, the younger brother of Northumberland, Hotspur's uncle, he makes him the second in command. So basically, you know, I mean, he's got responsibility for the Prince. He's essentially his governor. And so between them, Worcester and the Prince, you know, they're starting to have some successes. There's been a siege of Aberystwyth, a siege of Harlech. They managed to relieve those two sieges. And they also march on Owen's estates,
被授予威尔士战争的指挥权。但亨利四世再次小心翼翼，以免触怒珀西家族。因此，他任命伍斯特伯爵，即海军上将、诺森伯兰的弟弟、霍茨珀的叔叔，担任副指挥官。所以基本上，你知道，我的意思是，他负责王子的事务。他本质上是王子的监护人。因此，伍斯特和王子之间，你知道，他们开始取得一些成功。阿伯里斯特威斯和哈勒赫都曾被围困。他们成功解除了这两次围困。他们还向欧文的领地进军，
which amazingly, up until this point, hadn't been burnt. And they absolutely waste them, flatten them. So conditions aren't great, but Henry IV in London must be thinking, come on, it's going to be all right. The Percys are going to stick by me. And to make absolutely sure of this, he decides that he is going to march northwards to join Northumberland in this great war of invasion of Southern Scotland. Before he can set off, he gets very alarming news from Wales. He's told that owen glendower has
令人惊讶的是，直到现在，这些领地还没有被烧毁。他们彻底摧毁并夷平了这些地方。所以情况并不乐观，但身在伦敦的亨利四世一定在想，拜托，一切都会好起来的。珀西家族会支持我的。为了确保这一点，他决定向北进军，与诺森伯兰会合，参加这场入侵苏格兰南部的伟大战争。在他出发之前，他从威尔士收到了非常令人震惊的消息。有人告诉他，欧文·格林多已经
erupted out of central wales which by this point has been conquered by him and is heading southwards you know which is the most anglicized stretch of of wales it's been under english rule for a very long time um and messages say you've got to come to w Wales or else we're going to lose the whole principality. But Henry ignores these. You know, he's trusting the prince. He's trusting Worcester that they can handle the situation. He sends them a thousand pounds to kind of boost the fighting fund.
从威尔士中部爆发出来，那里此时已被他征服，他正向南进军，你知道，那是威尔士最英格兰化的一段，它在英国统治下已经很长时间了，嗯，消息说你必须来威尔士，否则我们将失去整个公国。但亨利忽略了这些。你知道，他信任王子。他信任伍斯特能处理好局势。他寄给他们一千英镑，以充实战斗资金。
But meanwhile, he remains committed to the invasion of southern Scotland. And he writes to Northumberland saying, you know, I'm coming northwards in order to give aid and comfort to our very dear and faithful cousins, the Earl of Northumberland saying, I'm coming northwards in order to give aid and comfort to our very dear and faithful cousins, the Earl of Northumberland and his son, I.E. Hotspur, of the battle honorably to be undertaken by them for us and our realm against our enemies, the Scots. So the Prince, Prince Hal, he's fighting in Wales. Henry IV is marching northwards
但与此同时，他仍然致力于入侵苏格兰南部。他写信给诺森伯兰说，你知道，我正向北进军，以便为我们非常亲爱和忠诚的表亲，诺森伯兰伯爵提供援助和安慰，说我正向北进军，以便为我们非常亲爱和忠诚的表亲，诺森伯兰伯爵和他的儿子，即霍茨珀，为我们和我们的王国对抗我们的敌人苏格兰人而光荣地进行战斗提供援助和安慰。所以王子，哈尔王子，他在威尔士战斗。亨利四世正在向北进军
from London up towards the frontier with Scotland. And on the 12th of July, he reaches Nottingham in the Midlands. And there, Dominic, he is given bombshell news. Bombshell. He is told Hotspur is not in the north. Hotspur has gone to Chester, that kind of hotbed of Ricardian support. And there, Hotspur is proclaiming that Richard II is still alive. What?
从伦敦向苏格兰边境进发。7月12日，他到达了中部地区的诺丁汉。在那里，多米尼克，他得到了一个重磅消息。重磅炸弹。他被告知霍茨珀不在北方。霍茨珀去了切斯特，那个理查二世支持者的温床。在那里，霍茨珀宣称理查二世还活着。什么？
And is summoning people to join him in a war against the usurper. Wow. Devastating. What a twist. That's very George R.R. Martin. So Hotspur has turned against Henry IV, his old friend, his old comrade-in-arms. It's all going to pieces in Wales.
并召集人们加入他，对抗篡位者。哇。太震撼了。真是个大反转。这非常有乔治·R·R·马丁的风格。所以霍茨珀背叛了亨利四世，他曾经的朋友，曾经的战友。威尔士的一切都乱套了。
Who knows what's going on in Scotland? Extraordinary scenes. Listen, if you want to hear the next part of Henry IV, Henry IV Part 2, in fact, and find out how this plays out, the Battle of Shrewsbury, the moment that the young Prince Hal, later Henry V, explodes onto the national stage. You can actually hear that episode right now by signing up at therestishistory.com
谁知道苏格兰发生了什么？非凡的场景。听着，如果你想听亨利四世的下一部分，事实上是亨利四世第二部分，并找出这一切是如何发展的，什鲁斯伯里战役，年轻的哈尔王子，后来的亨利五世，登上国家舞台的时刻。你现在就可以通过在therestishistory.com注册来收听那一集
and becoming a member of our much-loved Rest Is History Club. If you don't want to do that, you'll have to wait till Thursday and more for you. And on that bombshell, Tom, thank you very much and goodbye. Bye-bye. reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并成为我们备受喜爱的“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员。如果你不想这样做，你将不得不等到周四，还有更多内容等着你。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，非常感谢你，再见。再见。评论中夹杂着演艺圈的八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。